hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the timing of the senate's impeachment
trial against president trump remains
unclear
but could it end up overshadowing
president-elect joe biden's inauguration
day
fox news sunday host chris wallace
weighs in on impeachment the breach on
capitol hill
and tech companies banning president
trump
and with the 59th inauguration inching
closer the secret service and federal
law enforcement agencies are beefing up
security to prevent any further violence
former cia station chief and fox news
contributor daniel hoffman discusses
these scaled-up safety measures
and the threat of domestic terrorism
plus commentary from former utah
congressman
and fox news contributor jason chaffetz
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm ainsley earhart i'm brett baer i'm
katie pavlich and this
is the fox news rundown
friday january 15 2021 i'm chris foster
president trump after losing the
election and now after impeachment still
has a lot of supporters
the right at the capitol has a lot of
people turning their backs the biggest
punishment that the president got this
week it wasn't the impeachment
it was the pga announcing that they are
pulling
the major tournament the pga which is
you know the professional golf
association championship
from his golf course in bedminster new
jersey in 2022.
we speak with fox news sunday host chris
wallace i'm lisa brady
much of downtown d.c is already sealed
off
in preparation for next week's
inauguration an
earlier and stronger security presence
one lesson we learned from january 6
from those riots that had breached the
capital is we didn't have enough
state federal local law enforcement and
and military there to protect our
lawmakers
and i'm jason chaffetz i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's the end of president trump's last
full week in office a term he'll be
allowed to complete with any senate
impeachment trial waiting until after
joe biden is sworn in to replace him at
noon next wednesday
that could at least partially overshadow
president biden's agenda out of the gate
president trump meantime ends his time
in office without the social media he
used so prodigiously
and been blocked by all the major
services these are tense
and difficult times the efforts to
censor cancel and blacklist
our fellow citizens are wrong and they
are dangerous
but the president as we heard in that
video he released wednesday can still
use the power of the office to get out
any message he wants and right now his
message
is one of unity i'm calling on all
americans to overcome the passions of
the moment and join together as
one american people he says now let's
try to find common ground
and shared purpose he put out this video
on wednesday
and mob violence and you know we're
against any of that
and our supporters and our movement is
for all for law and order
chris boss is the host of fox news
sunday i would have been a lot more
impressed
if he had uh released that video
around two o'clock on wednesday january
6th
not six o'clock on wednesday january
13th
uh you know i remember uh
as a kid my mother saying you know
sometimes sorry doesn't cut it
and sorry a week after the fact i i just
don't
i'm not impressed by it but you know i'm
sure others are
well if he put on that video on january
6 at 2pm he
might not might not have gotten himself
impeached oh
i think that there's absolutely uh well
on the sixth i'm not sure it might have
been too late if he put it out on the
fifth
and maybe not even held the rally in the
first place i mean
you do have to ask yourself what is the
president doing it's january 6
he's put out uh tweets saying you know
come show up on the six
it's gonna be a wild one uh you know
this is the day we fight
uh for the election uh and then you hold
this this
rally with tens of thousands of people
and
and call out mike pence and say you know
i hope he's going to do the right thing
and you say
i'm never going to accept the election
we're never going to concede
and let's all walk down to the capitol
now did he say break the windows did he
say
chant hang mike pence did he say bring
handcuffs and ask where's nancy
uh and endanger the lives of our elected
representatives no but
boy um he you know look i'm i'm
not some wild-eyed liberal outside in
this particular case with uh
liz cheney and uh and mitch mcconnell
who basically said that
uh he stacked the firewood and he lit
the flame
there were republicans at the
impeachment uh debate
saying that look if this is just going
to make things worse we should move on
and there are still republicans saying
look there was fraud in the election
uh we're at the same time those 10
democrats and the republic the democrat
those 10 republicans excuse me and the
democrats
say that no he needs to be punished for
ginning up his base like this and for
these false election claims not just
that day but in the weeks and months
prior
yeah um you know i look do i think
that it's the best thing for the country
to have a senate trial
on inauguration day or the or the first
full day the 21st of the
bride's administration probably not and
you know we do have more
urgent and pressing matters particularly
if after the president has left office
like uh confirming a government you know
we haven't had
a single hearing yet on uh a secretary
of homeland security secretary defense
secretary of the treasury uh you know
all those things
um so you know and he's got an emergency
covered relief package
to deal both with vaccinations and with
economic relief
you know i do think congress needs to be
going full speed ahead on that
um you know i don't know uh i i honestly
am mixed on the on the trial because i
do think
that the president's involvement in all
of this was extraordinary and deeply
damaging to the country
and i'm not sure it doesn't need to be
adjudicated and maybe the answer is just
impeachment because you know it sends a
bad message i i understand why democrats
might want it
to have the trial first to to punish the
president and two
if he's gets off that uh you know then
they have put uh some republicans in
tough spots when they're up for
for re-election in 2022 and four uh
but but on the other hand uh you know it
does
it does divide the country i'm you know
i'm i i'd like to think i pretty strong
opinions or analysis about uh about most
things this one i'm not sure about
yeah you know two two impeachment listen
you know what
the biggest punishment that the
president got this week it wasn't the
impeachment
it was the pga announcing that they are
pulling
the major tournament the pga which is
you know the professional golf
association championship
from his golf course in bedminster new
jersey in 2022.
i promise you that hurt him more than
the second impeachment
well the word i read from somebody from
a source uh was that he was quote gutted
by that decision i mean he's he's
financially
and to an extent politically other than
his supporters he's a man without a
country now
and and legally he's in real jeopardy um
whether
he pardons himself and there's some
question whether that would stand or not
but it certainly doesn't stand for state
prosecutions and we know that
the new york attorney general the new
york city district attorney are all
looking at
at issues uh financially uh
you know that he if you believe the new
york times story owes hundreds of
thousands
or hundreds of millions of dollars
rather uh
and and you know there's a lot of
liability in addition to which i mean i
got to think
if you're one of the trump kids you're
thinking to yourself uh and not to say
that they weren't participants in all of
this themselves
but you know is it going to be harder to
get
people an event at a trump golf course
or
at a trump hotel is it going to be
harder to get people to uh
to live in a trump branded uh apartment
building
luxury apartment building um i think i
think
he's in for some tough times which may
be one of the reasons he fought
so hard to hold on to power for all this
talk of
asking president biden to ask that look
let's just all move on his supporters
might feel betrayed by that i mean there
were people who wanted president obama
to punish members of the bush
administration for
for some things they did and he just
moved on what do you think joe biden
will do
i don't know um you know he's he hasn't
wanted to be part of this fight he's
really stayed out of it and said that's
up for congress
to decide um you know again
i think he knows that his mark as
president
is not going to be made by what happens
to donald trump it's going to be made by
what happens on the public health crisis
we're facing now the economic crisis
we're facing now
and his very ambitious agenda uh
that he's pushing right now so um you
know i i don't know what he's gonna do
i'll tell you what he isn't gonna do
you know we always have that grace note
at the beginning of a of an inaugural
address
um where the the you know the the new
president
says and i you know i don't honestly
remember what trump did with
with obama in in 2017 but i know what
obama did with bush in 20 uh
2009 or or bush with uh
with clinton in 2001 where they you know
thank the president and praise him even
if it's a little hard to do
for what uh what he did and his
stewardship of the country
over the past four or eight years i
don't think you're going to hear that
from joe biden
looking at the attack investigation just
talking about the riot the capital for
one more time um
have you spoken with anyone about claims
that the writers had help do you think
this is going to be a huge huge scandal
i do the answer is i don't know i have
spoken i did last week
i interviewed this last sunday i
interviewed jim clyburn
the number three democrat in the house
the house majority whip
and he told me a very telling story he
said that
he had an office right off the road at
the statuary hall on the on the main
floor of the capitol
and it says majority whip and james
clyburn on it
and he said during the riot that office
was never touched
and he said meanwhile he's got kind of a
hideaway where his staff
works and he works much more than in the
ceremonial office
up on the third floor you know that
people don't even kind of know
exists and he said there were rioters
banging on that door
so he he says i'm not going to charge it
but he said i certainly
wonder whether they had inside help as
to where
i might really be and where my staff
might really be
and of course you heard that on the
floor of the house this week
with people talking about uh you know
members of republicans
holding tours the day before were they
giving tours to people who ended up
participating in the riots
you know this is where things are
there's questions about capitol hill
police
you know that's one of the really
disturbing things this whole
thing there were there were people there
who were armed outfitted and seemed
prepared with tactical
expertise whether they were current or
former police officers
current or former military uh there were
some people
who had training that helped them
in carrying out this right i mean you
know the bottom line here chris
is we are so lucky that it wasn't so
much worse
you know they came so close you know you
look at the timeline
they came so close to getting their
hands on
members of the senate the vice president
of the united states the speaker of the
house
members of the house you know think what
happens then if it's a hostage situation
and you know there's talk that some of
them wanted to put
uh mike pence the vice president on
trial
uh saying that you know he was was
stealing the election from donald trump
this
it was horrible unforgettable i've
certainly never
experienced anything in my life but it
could have been even worse
uh president trump can still send out
press he's going out more quietly than
he's
then he's conducted himself with with no
social media now he can still send out
press releases and videos through the
white house he's still obviously got a
huge
uh platform he and his supporters say
that this is censorship the people
running the services say no it's about
preventing more violence if you put a
lot of thought into it
yeah i i mean i i have i have mixed
feelings i'm obviously
i'm a a free speech person this isn't a
first amendment issue
because that says government shall make
no law and twitter
and uh facebook and you know google
they're not
free they're not government they're
private companies and they have leeway
to do things that are not in
contravention
of the first amendment uh i'm a free
speech guy and i'm so i'm
generally very much in favor of that but
you know free speech does have limits
the one that we always talk about is you
can't shout fire in a crowded theater
um you know public safety is a is a
limit on free speech
and you can certainly understand how
companies
would feel that that after the events of
last wednesday
that it's dangerous to have those voices
on their platforms now having said that
it's a slippery slope
because you know there's a lot of junk
on twitter and other places and you've
got the ayatollah
uh hominay of iran and other
bloodthirsty people have twitter
platforms so
you know how do you draw the line but i
can't
condem twitter after last wednesday for
reacting and saying you know we we need
to be careful that we're not doing
anything
to uh you know to
enable an insurrection a lot of measured
opinions out of you this week chris
wallace
i like to think there are always
measured opinions with us
chris wallace host of fox news sunday
thanks a lot hey i'll talk to you during
the bite administration
yes i'll talk to you as we always say
you know i think it's very clever
i'll talk to you next year talk to you
in the next president
[Music]
this is jason chaffetz with your fox
news commentary
coming up the nation's capital is
looking more and more
like an encampment teeming with troops
ahead of next week's inauguration as the
investigation continues
into last week's deadly security breach
as the president made clear yesterday
we are committed to an orderly
transition
into a safe inauguration and the
american people deserve nothing less
vice president mike pence receiving a
security briefing at fema headquarters
thursday
from several agencies including the fbi
our posture is aggressive it's going to
stay that way through the inauguration
fbi director christopher wray says
they've arrested more than 100 people
over last week's violent siege and
they've identified
dozens more with agents hunting them
down across the country
but there are more potential threats
including calls for armed protest
we are seeing an extensive amount
of concerning online chatter is the best
way i would describe it about a number
of events
surrounding the inauguration and
together with our partners
we evaluate those threats and what kind
of resources to deploy against them
the secret service director says
inaugural planning had already been
underway for months and they're highly
confident in that plan but always
wide-eyed and sober
the reinforcements ordered after the
deadly capital attack
could total more than 20 000 national
guard troops
and thousands of active duty troops
first of all it's a general principle
that you really want to present
overwhelming force to deter would-be
attackers
from launching against you dan hoffman
is a former cia
station chief and a fox news contributor
if you're trying to protect an
installation
and you have too much defense too many
troops
that that's okay you know if after
the inauguration we look back and say
well we had twenty thousand national
guard but we only needed ten
that's all right one lesson we learned
from january 6 from those
riots that breached the capital is we
didn't have enough
state federal local law enforcement and
and military there to protect our
lawmakers
and there's an unknown out there right
now we know that
that certain installations are under
threat
but there could be additional violence
that we need to be prepared for and i
think that's why we want to have as much
um as much force as we can i know the
fbi has said
after the attack that it did warn law
enforcement about
possible plans for violence at the
capitol
but when investigators are tracking
groups online for instance
how difficult is it to distinguish
between just talk
and actual planning and at what point
can law enforcement act on that
well that's you know the challenge
certainly that that the fbi
faces but they do this on a very regular
basis certainly when it comes to
domestic or foreign terrorists in our
country
the fbi collects lots of intelligence
from sources from
sources in their networks they scrape
the social media network sites
they put all that information together
and
produce essentially all source analysis
so that
state federal local law enforcement can
make good decisions about where the
threats are
and seek to eliminate those threats
before they materialize
that was the failure on january 6
reportedly
there was no there were no analytical
reports received
from dhs or from fbi and
some of the state local law enforcement
the capitol police felt like they didn't
know enough
about the threat beforehand now i think
they could have been asking for these
sorts of reports because it was pretty
well known
that there was going to be a large
gathering of people um
in the nation's capital and and that was
certainly well known and there was lots
of reporting on it
um but certainly i think your point is
right the the
collecting the information analyzing it
right so that you can put it to use is
of critical value
we've heard the term domestic terrorists
used often lately
to describe the capital rioters
is that a is that a legal term and what
does it actually mean
so it's a term that's you know
commonly used obviously for
foreign non-state actors and the the use
you know terrorism the definition of
it's an unlawful use of violence or
intimidation
against civilians to pursue political
aims
and so when we talk about domestic
terrorism
uh that's what you know you could apply
that to if you think that
that a group of violent extremists
are conducting uh perpetrating violent
acts against
civilians to pursue political aims then
a lawyer might argue that they are
guilty of domestic terrorism
i know with the international terrorism
component
in particular we started to hear a lot
over the years about the risk of
lone wolf attacks is there also a risk
of that
with domestic terrorism because you know
there's concerns about extremists
either from the far left or the far
right and if they
don't have a centralized target let's
say if we
go around and sort of harden all the
obvious you know public
targets um would there be more of a
concern then
of them trying to stage more
individualized attacks is that something
that the intelligence community is
you know looks at regularly yeah so i
have a couple of concerns certainly
about
lone wolf attacks first of all
when our focus is on these large
gatherings of individuals seeking to
attack a particular installation
sometimes
that's precisely when a foreign or
domestic terrorist
be it a lone wolf terrorist might seek
to strike
when our resources are stretched
and that can present a great challenge
to us and the second point i would make
is look back at the recent attack in
nashville
that was one person who caused
extraordinary
uh you know disrupted cell phone
activity disrupted 911 service
imagine if this there were attacks that
were
combined in such a way that first
responders were unable to communicate
and there were violent acts that were
being perpetrated
and if foreign terrorists know that
16 to 20 january is precisely when we
are at the greatest risk of of domestic
unrest they may seek to take advantage
by
targeting our infrastructure
communications and other things
so this is a particularly you know
dangerous time it's when our law
enforcement
at the federal local and state level
they are on the hook
to do the hard work now again they've
been doing this for 20 years
and they do a great job of it but make
no mistake it's extraordinarily
challenging and it's an all hands on
deck kind of scenario
we certainly did have a major security
shift
in the us really and around the world
after 9 11 happened will the threats of
today
lead to another intense shift in how we
secure the us i mean i guess the
security landscape is always kind of
evolving
but what kind of changes could you see
happening now
i think you know we think we do a great
job overall i think where we
failed um on january 6
it doesn't necessarily require that we
do anything different it's that we
we need to be doing the things that we
have done up to this point successfully
so there was plenty of intelligence
plenty of information plenty of
information scraped from social media
networking sites we knew
where there were large numbers of people
coming to washington dc to protest
and it would have been easy enough to
find out who they are
and to know the risks that that they
posed to the capital
and we failed to put helicopters
overhead to track them we failed
to have the overwhelming force at the
capitol that would have deterred them or
prevented them from breaching the
capital
so those were all failures um
but we kind of knew that beforehand and
so i think they'll
go back we'll go back over this there'll
be accountability there will be lessons
learned those lessons will be
internalized and we'll go forward and do
better frankly
i i you know i believe we're fortunate
that january 6 didn't turn out to be
worse than it was
in the immediate aftermath of the
capital attack
there were the resignations of the house
and senate sergeant
sergeants at arms and also the the
capital
police chief is that fair
i mean should they have maybe waited for
the investigation to really get going or
was that uh
were those important steps just to
you know kind of show some early
accountability if you will
yeah i think so i i think it's a great
point that you make because
i didn't feel like they should have been
so quick to resign i think they should
stay
and assist with the accountability you
know they're gone now
and um maybe they would still have maybe
they would have been fired who knows
but they should have stuck around and
helped
those who were staying understand where
things went wrong and so i think they
did
um those those decisions that they made
to resign i think those were precipitous
decisions and they shouldn't have
i think the accountability is all about
looking at what went wrong
and and there's we still are in you know
kind of incident response collecting the
facts on what went wrong we need to do
it quickly
but we certainly haven't finished
collecting all those facts and learning
all those lessons
hopefully we've learned enough to
protect ourselves in the coming days
dan i know you have a wide ranging
background
not only with the cia but the military
the state department
what advice would you give to the
incoming administration at this point
as far as domestic terrorism is
concerned sure domestic terrorism
security in general the the u.s security
posture you know what i've what i've
learned over the years is this
um there are three stages of
intelligence essentially the first is
collecting the information
and that can be you know online it could
be through human sources but it's
collecting raw data
the second stage is analyzing that data
so taking everything you know
including you know open source
information whatever you've got
and then doing what we call all source
analysis and then the third stage is
making
good decisions based on the analysis if
you do all those three things if you
collect information
and you analyze it properly your and you
make an
informed executive decision that's the
right one you've got an intelligent
success
if you fail at any one of those stages
you've got a failure and of course we
saw that on january
6. that i think applies to national
security that is what
national security is all about it's why
that i was so honored to serve at cia
for so many years because
we were on that you know out there on
the front lines recruiting spies i'm
stealing secrets i know my old boss john
brennan didn't like to call it that but
that's what it was
and that's what matters for our national
security
and our executive decision makers
starting with president-elect biden need
to demand
the best intelligence we've got the best
analysis we've got
so that that he and his team can make
the best decisions if you look at some
of the successes of the trump
administration
uh for example you know destroying isis
dealing with iran and and targeting
successfully targeting the the
general qasim sulaimani the head of the
kutz force
destroying al qaeda leadership al-qaeda
in the arabian peninsula the the leader
of that
of that branch of al-qaeda kasim al-rimi
all of those successes were intelligence
based
i know secretary pompeo over at the
state department
of course he was director cia he knew
how to read the intelligence and use it
to produce the best kind of diplomacy
that he could and that
that's really i think critical for for
this
new administration is to get that right
um and ensure that there's that
flow of information and analysis to the
decision makers so they can make you
know the most educated decisions
dan hoffman always appreciate your
insight thank you very much for your
time
my pleasure all the best
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
in the wake of the riot at the u.s
capitol many stories have circulated
and one of them has featured eugene
goodman he's the capital police officer
who kept a group of rioters carrying
confederate flags and weapons away from
the senate chambers
video shows him holding the group back
then retreating up some stairs in the
opposite direction of the chamber
entrance which some police experts say
was a tactic
to draw the rioters away from the
lawmakers staff members and reporters
inside
goodman is being held as a hero with
bipartisan accolades from some of those
in the house of representatives
three house members republican nancy
mace of south carolina democrat emmanuel
cleaver of missouri
and democrat charlie crist of florida
have announced the introduction of a
bill to award officer goodman with the
congressional gold medal for his bravery
and quick thinking
past recipients include frank sinatra
rosa parks the little rock nine and dr
martin luther king jr
goodman also served in the army from
2002 to 2006
and was deployed with the 101st airborne
for a year to iraq
the 18th airborne corps at fort bragg
recognized goodman in a tweet saying he
is quote
rightfully being hailed as a hero after
single-handedly holding back rioters
from entering the senate chambers
and goes on to say eugene was a hero
long before january 6th
and that they celebrate his valor so do
we
officer goodman tanya jai powers fox
[Music]
news
it's time for your fox news commentary
jason chaffetz
what's on your mind never let it be said
that democrats let crises of the past 12
months go to waste
with the coronavirus pandemic forced
closures of large swaths of the economy
and civil unrest
the left did what it always does in
times of crisis
leveraged disaster for political gain it
worked
so we can expect to see a lot more of it
the left has
continued its crusade to suppress
conservative views
in many forms earlier leftists gutted
election security procedures
using the pandemic as their
justification
democratic office holders have managed
to amplify false narratives and conceal
true ones with the help of partners
in the left-wing media powerful social
media platforms
the non-profit sector and government
there seemed to be
no line the democrats wouldn't cross to
capitalize on america's misfortunes
welcome to disaster liberalism and
buckle up
now that the success of those efforts
has given democrats bare majorities in
the u.s house and senate
along with the presidency as of
wednesday we can expect them to double
down on the tactics that work so well
for them
in 2020. given the choice between
moderating their positions to attract
more support
and claiming a crisis to strip away
checks on their power
the democrats will choose the latter the
crisis
of the past 12 months provide the
pretext by which leftists achieve their
goal
now that democrats have the power they
sought we can expect them to continue to
leverage
real crisis exaggerate small ones and
fabricate new ones
to justify exponentially bigger power
grabs
for the left crisis has change but the
solutions are always the same
more government less freedom and higher
taxes
unfortunately for democrats our recent
crisis came
during a republican presidency under the
stewardship of a man
who showed little appetite for
leveraging the crises
to expand federal power i shudder to
think what this country would look like
today
had hillary clinton held the reins of
presidency during the coronavirus
pandemic
but even with a republican president and
senate to check their power
democrats managed to leverage the crisis
that have engulfed america in ways that
did great damage to our country
even as president trump prepares to
leave office we see the strategy playing
out
democrats spent years justifying
violence they told us
when we saw violent far-left occupy and
black lives matter protests
that this is what democracy looks like
they used facebook and twitter to
organize large-scale violence
but now the tables have turned suddenly
democrats are
no longer claiming that protests are
mostly peaceful
when some participants turned violent
now they justify the suppression of an
entire political party
suddenly social media are a dangerous
place to organize
but only for those who oppose democrats
all others can continue to organize
their violent protest
unimpeded we can expect to see much more
punitive responses to speech the left
labels unpopular
we will see efforts to punish or
retaliate against those
who would undermine the majority
position no longer will we hear that
this is what democracy looks like for
the good of the country we need to
resist efforts to use disasters
as a justification for running roughshod
over constitutional protections
while democrats control the federal
legislative and executive branches
republicans hold the majority of state
legislatures
we must hold the line on defending and
enforcing the checks and balances
that protect us from a majority that has
clearly signaled
its preference for tyranny i'm jason
chaffetz
former member of congress and a fox news
contributor
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say
alexa play news from fox in fox news
it's the latest when you need it on
demand
from fox news and amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes